i've never had a burnout ever i've been  and i've been i've been going like this  for for uh  a long time  decade 35 40 years even i mean i started  going at it in my teens hard and and  i never had that burnout and i think  that's kind of a state of mind that uh  if you're going to get burnt out if you  want to get burnt out but but i always  was going like this and so i just kind  of felt like i'm so fortunate to to to  have it going why should i ever let the  momentum go the other way  and then of course you know one of my  great sayings is there's positive people  and negative people and and when you're  with a negative person or you're with a  positive person one of two things is  going to happen the negative person is  going to make the positive person  negative or you're going to take the  negative person and make them positive  so i've always paid attention to who  i've always been around also and and  i never wanted to be around people that  didn't want to achieve